you know like what do you know like
orange orange orange is the worst
flavoring known to man i think orange is
like orange
orange has to be like
okay i i said strawberry from australian
sarcasm why are you like actually
seriously i i know we said that
strawberry was down there and now that i
reminded me because i must have blocked
it out because i don't want to exist
strawberry is by far by far i think the
worst flavor of any fruit it's so bad
strawberry oh sorry uh orange sorry
orange is such a chocolate oh my gosh
it's good but it needs to help it right
but the moment you get just orange on
its own i don't like too much chocolate
orange flavor sucks but orange chocolate
though the orange chocolate damn it's
the rare combination where two flavors
if they you know they they drop their
differences they can come together make
something decent but
i already i hate chocolate i hate orange
orange chocolate two negatives yeah
through negatives make a plus it's where
you should never rule out possibilities
right i just think that orange sorbet
awful like orange flavored drinks orange
flavored ice cream oh it's just so bad
it's just so bad i think i think i think
i figured it out connor just has some of
the most skewed taste
like
food that i've ever seen where it's like
you you really like what you really like
but you really don't like what you
really do i just think that like and you
are so [ __ ] particular about [ __ ] if
i went to a restaurant and
all i had for dessert no i'm not i just
i
i was
like no is he not like someone who won't
eat it like if you give me an orange
sorbet i'm going to eat it but i'm going
to be begrudgingly annoyed the whole
time that you gave me an orange so
you're just a stubborn picky eater no no
no i will eat anything i go to ryokan
you give me this [ __ ] slimy thing i'll
i'll stomach it and i'll be like fine
i'll [ __ ] eat this slimy thing i
don't want to eat but i'll eat it like i
really because every neocon we've been
to together you've passed me the slimy
[ __ ] immediately if you're gonna eat it
let's let's let's move back for a second
my point being is a picky eater somebody
doesn't eat it i will always eat it
right yeah let's move back for a second
what is this
tirade against oranges what it's
literally the vanilla of the fruit world
how'd you hate how do you hate oranges
it is such it's not gonna cause vanilla
is quite mild in flavor right it's a
very like light flavor it's not intense
orange is a very intense flavor you just
hate it it's so acidic
okay let me guess do you like orange
juice no i hate orange we've said this
before i hate orange juice do you just
like because the thing is oranges are so
[ __ ] refreshing
stuff it's like acid [ __ ] how weak
is it
fruit juice
you know i feel literally most fruit
juices
of the citrus family lemon and lime
absolutely god tier they figured it out
how to make it refreshing you literally
want to have a raw lemon versus having a
raw orange
yeah definitely
are you serious like i know i know lemon
is like more acidic but like the flavors
that you get in like lemonade are less
acidic than you get and say orange juice
like orange juice is always way more
acidic yeah that's because lemonade is
very different to lemon juice yeah i
know lemon-flavored things are also
nicer i find
there's so much [ __ ] that's being
spewed right now that like i'm having a
trouble processing like orange juice is
is awful like it's just a it's just a
bad drink like it just doesn't taste
good you're so you are so wrong so wrong
i mean you're
just there's there's not enough well
there's not enough hats in the world to
indicate how much cap that is man that's
like i'm just trying to there's viewers
out there who are watching this who know
that orange is [ __ ] who knows that
sorbet is bad who knows that chocolate
is too much yeah
orange is like orange is your altar
count
orange is like by like it's probably
like one of the worst fruits no no
like aren't people that's truly the
worst first so also orange is just a
miserable eating experience it's just
terrible what how are you eating about
are you eating the rind like it's just
like a banana [ __ ] easy as [ __ ] you
should get it what do you want do you
know a thing there is a thing called a
knife
banana no knife needed i love that
why i want to [ __ ] have to peel this
open like a caveman banana easy bro you
lit you just [ __ ] cut it into
quarters
the banana has an elegancy to it the the
orange you got to [ __ ] pry it open
like a caveman scrambling for his meal
you literally have to do that with a
lemon and a lime as well though i don't
eat [ __ ] lemon and limes on their own
you literally just said you would rather
eat a raw lemon than an orange i would
never do it there's an elegance he says
the banana you could it's oh yes oh yes
yes
don't mind if i do there's an elegance
he says talking about the fruit literal
apes eat you know there's a reason why
they
they don't want to fumble around with an
orange it just makes more sense it
literally has two iq like
he's just like too many steps
also i just think the texture of like a
i just think everything about the orange
i just dislike like when the texture of
eating an orange i feel like the texture
oh no like the texture of bananas are
like not good it's way it's way worse it
gets way too much it gets weighted it
gets way too mushy
okay okay look it's it's a gamble with a
banana sometimes you've got to have the
perfect texture for it to be like yeah
that was a [ __ ] amazing look
sometimes the banana can be too hard
sometimes it's just a [ __ ]
thing that banana has the best texture
of any fruit no it does when it's when
it's the optimal texture to be it has to
be
better than any fruit
cat no i watermelon still better stop no
no no no a perfectly ripe banana is the
best vegetable strawberry strawberry
watermelon watermelon watermelon is good
that's no not enough taste not enough
taste
strawberries like the pop rocks of fruit
excuse me it's okay
what did you say huh there's not enough
taste in watermelon
it's a very light flavor it's a very
very light flavor it's diluted it's
mostly it's literally mostly water yeah
i like it i will say
out of all the names like our orange is
pretty good i mean i assume the color
was named after the fruit yeah yeah but
watermelon yeah they were pretty ripe i
called your watermelon yeah yeah
yeah i'm not getting click-baited
yeah yeah i know exactly what i'm going
in for with the watermelon and you you
have a better time with that orange
melon is better than watermelon just
because there's too much water in the
watermelon
there just far too much water like i am
getting way too hydrated eating a
watermelon how can you say that apple
juice is the worst juice no so how can
you say that orange juice is the worst
juice when apple juice exists yeah that
is i think i think juice is literally
that is water that that is like that is
like
toddler they are like they are like they
are like neck and neck to me like apple
juice just
apple juice just wins in my mind because
it's not orange but it is just as bad
what are you what is this orange slander
orange what is this orange racist
the worst fruit i think it's by far what
did oranges ever do to you i don't know
just completely my entire life every
time i've tried it i just think this
tastes like [ __ ] like did you get beaten
up at school by kid wearing an orange
shirt
ancestry of scurvy and [ __ ] like i would
rather get scurvy than even orange
bet
i'd rather would i would scurvy
challenge incoming let's go
i just don't want to i just don't want i
just don't know what about what about
orange zest when when when there's a
dessert or something like fancy dessert
are you curious what about orange
liqueur i'd rather not if i don't like
again i'd rather any other i'd like any
other uh citrus liqueur if possible i
like literally i'm trying to like
process
what where this hatred comes on comes
from because i'm like
maybe
maybe it's like the acidity i don't know
then you you go you come here and say
you'd rather eat a raw lemon than
[ __ ] did your father throw oranges at
you when you like misbehaved
that's what i just think it's the like
you ha there has to be a worse fruit in
your mind right what's the worst than an
orange in your mind what's the worst
fruit the worst fruit dragon fruit
oh it's such a cop out what what do you
mean it's a [ __ ] people don't [ __ ]
eat that at any time like it's just
talking about niche fruit you're talking
about fruit that we can buy from fruit
that you can get
in like a daily life yeah you can get
dragon fruit no you're [ __ ] good
because you can't you can't no you can't
don't no maybe in australia where you
have like every kind of life kind of
privileged life are you leading where
you can get [ __ ] dragon yeah i'm from
australia
i'm one place in japan where you can buy
dragon fruit that's near you right now
uh literally the supermarket in my house
sells dragon fruit bro what was your
supermarket some got like [ __ ] whole
foods uh erin like that's a privilege
right there that that's actually
privilege that is a privilege indication
yeah except it's like a tiny [ __ ]
corner there's like two dragon fruits at
most you know i'm still there i've never
even seen dragon fruit in the store
you're probably not working okay so that
doesn't count because [ __ ] food
doesn't exist okay so like a common
fruit right common fruit
what's the worst fruit the fruit that
you would you when you thought about
anything like no no i'd rather not you
know i'm trying to think and i know
you're trying to pull something out of
us i literally can't think of a fruit i
just don't like what a cop out i i just
i'm i'm sorry i just like fruits okay
if i had to like pick something okay
this is okay no i figured it out this is
this is just me personally but for me
it's grapes
what yeah i'm not a massive fan grape's
a god what are you talking about joey
you like wine how can you hate grapes
how could you
that's like saying how could you hate
bread you like beer it's like there's
nothing alive i have to say grapes are
the like and this is this puts it in s
here for me grapes yeah it's the only
fruit where you can always get the
perfect amount of the fruit that you
want like you can have as many grapes as
that suits you always if you want a [ __ ]
ton of grapes go down go to town and
it's also such a satisfying eating
experience
i don't know i'm just not a massive fan
of grapes i'll eat grapes but like i
would rather ha i would rather cut an
orange open than eat some grapes i'm
gonna say this that's just me personally
though i'm just gonna say it i'm i'm a
vegetable guy all the way i think
vegetables are so goddamn superior to
fruit in every single way you just hate
desserts you just you just say sweet i
just like sweet stuff like vegetables
are just so much better you hate sweet
stuff if it's not vanilla like if if i
had to pick guns on my head worse fruit
even though i don't really hate it
probably apple
like there's there is no
experience eating an apple it's like
there is no category that apple goes in
that is that can't be beaten by another
fruit i think i i think it's one of
those things i like i like i like green
apples i'm not huge into red apples i
don't like red granny green red granny
smith yeah green ones randy smith green
apples banger i i it's i know i really
like eating apples actually but it's
just a lot like there's always a lot of
apples yeah it's one of them it's
actually i think it's the most filling
uh fruit oh absolutely yeah absolutely
and it feels like you eat like ate a
[ __ ] a380 it's like it's a whole meal
so much food like if the apples be
especially in japan where the apples are
like [ __ ] this big like that's a meal
um so yeah that's kind of where i stand
on it i just think vegetables are the
superior ones they're more look don't
give me something so
also vegetables are better for you just
saying is that the reason why you hate
sorbets just because you hate [ __ ]
fruit yeah i hate fruit flavored things
so if that wasn't
figured it out you just hate [ __ ] so
if there was a vegetable flavored sorbet
would you oh [ __ ] no that sounds awful
why would you want that just just a
hypothetical no no no no i i would want
i i just want okay first of all don't
want a sorbet i feel like the texture of
it is just the worst i could like i
think a vegetable sorbet could work i
just gelato like a like a gelato and
soft serve and normal ice cream all the
way
but like sometimes you sometimes don't
maybe there are sometimes never an
occasion where i will say no there are
there are some times where you've had
such a [ __ ] filling heavy
main course but you still want something
just to like take the edge off because
let's be real
let's be real that whole saying of like
oh dessert is another stomach it's
[ __ ] oh no no no no it's not it's
actually not it's proved that you're
stuck you can actually make more room
for dessert because the way i can't the
way that it works with sweet and salty
is that you can trick your brain into
thinking that there's more room than
there is i'm sure that's why you over
eat i'm sure at the time yeah but i know
for a fact i stopped myself from doing
it because i know i'm gonna be sick
afterwards like there's been a lot of
studies on this you you can actually
make way more room when you're when you
have something sweet right
i do notice well that's just a variety
of meals
if you have one of like the same thing
over and over you can eat you can you
gotta eat less of it but it's emphasized
when you go for something savory it's
something really sweet
uh just because of how i don't know how
like chocolate brains work yeah
um so but yeah the great thing about ice
cream is the moment you eat it it
becomes a liquid so it will definitely
fit in there so does sorbet it'll make
room
in fact
in fact
is more liquidy wait no no you're
putting your argument on me i never said
that it's too heavy you're you're you
just put your [ __ ] argument on to my
ice cream love i never said ice cream
was too heavy i never said sorbet was
too heavy well we are arguing sometimes
ice cream is too heavy
it's not it can't be too heavy because
it'll always fit in your [ __ ] stomach
that's not the point the point is the
feeling of it right and cream is way
heavier way heavier fruit juice it is if
i if i use the same amount of ice cream
versus the same amount of sorbet i would
feel more sick with the ice cream yeah
that's all they like like the exact the
exact same for the exact same reason why
you can't eat too much chocolate ice
cream versus too much vanilla ice cream
it's because vanilla ice cream feels
lighter than the chocolate well i mean
it's just it's not so much there it's
more it just feels more i don't know why
it makes me feel sick immediately i
don't even know what we're arguing about
anymore
i'm trying to argue understand too many
arguments happening at the same time
it's just this is just there's so many
[ __ ] takes that has been just been said
in like uh 10 minutes
we just turned preferences into like
solid set in stone takes that must be
followed yeah because you're making it
that way i'm just saying my opinion and
then you guys are like connor has an
opinion what
i said that's it i just said i think
orange is a dog [ __ ] which they are
chocolate as a flavor kind of sucks
everyone knows that vanilla is the best
uh well we can we have the right to uh
[ __ ] argue your shitty opinion you
know
i'm not saying that this is like you
know 100 that's what it has to be all i
am is calling you a clown and i i think
i think that's fair
you're entitled to your opinion but you
definitely said the most unpopular
opinion well we don't know because we've
had takes before where i've said it and
you guys are like no you're dumb as [ __ ]
and then all the comments are like nah
connor's right come on this is the trash
dates audience
well the whole it's the whole keyboard
thing all over again i was completely in
the right there and i was i was un
unjustified and i was i was uh
reprimanded for no reason and i was
completely in the right with the
keyboard argument god forbid you're
correct sometimes
i've got this is gaslight central i'm
always getting gasoline here on trash
taste it's very fun i just can't believe
you hate oranges i've never met a person
hate orange no i mean he's never asked
the the only person
but the only person i know who doesn't
like oranges is someone who's like
allergic to oranges what no no no
there's a lot of people out there who
don't like orange it tastes bad
i guess i'm sure in the comment section
we'll meet a lot of people what are you
follow like-minded oranges not someone i
want to be friends with that's for sure
what if someone in your family doesn't
like orange what if you don't know i'll
[ __ ] clown on them for the rest of my
life
what if aki just turns around
i just can't absolutely clown it for it
i just can't imagine a world where you
just i can't imagine what we don't eat
your [ __ ] crusts
plenty of people don't need that crust
actually plenty of people don't eat them
we're gonna bring
don't pretend like this is where you
draw the line this is i don't know
everything else goes out the window
because orange is no that's where i'm
like that i'm i'm not i'm not i'm not
saying that i'm not i think we can all
agree that we are all clowns but today
we get to clown on this [ __ ] clown
we've all we're all guilty of having a
couple of opinions added to the [ __ ]
list but you just added another entry
onto yours we'll see we'll see we'll see
we'll see all the view i'm pretty cocky
there'll be a lot of fellow orange
haters out there
i guess let us know in the comments if
you're an orange hater or an orange
lover
sucks fanta sucks it's the worst fans of
socks don't give me just tastes like
[ __ ] orange fancy socks like what world
would you pick phantom like yeah but
orange fanta doesn't taste anything like
orange no
orange orange soda doesn't taste like a
little too much like orange for my taste
no it's got it's like like orange fanta
sucks because it's artificial orange
taste if something actually tastes it's
the same reason why i hate every art is
the same reason why i hate strawberry
ice cream yeah and other artificial
tasting fruits uh it's fruit flavors
it's because it doesn't actually taste
like the [ __ ] fruit we'll see what
the comments say we'll see
he's like running to the comments like
guys help me
yeah like i'm just more shocked that you
have such a strong opinion towards
[ __ ] oranges they just suck
i just i
can't you'll catch me first okay
i can understand i can understand if
your opinion was you know i'm not really
like a fan of oranges um but like i know
i've never seen someone so
spies and orange yeah spite oranges they
just suck they just [ __ ] suck
oh my god this is enough fruit slander
before i
have an aneurysm yeah yeah i'm gonna
have a nice orange
flavored dessert you know what i love
you know i'm gonna go home
you know what i actually love orange i'm
gonna go to my local supermarket
i'm going to buy a couple of oranges i'm
going to buy a dragon fruit and i'm
going to have a good time actually you
know i [ __ ] like now it's just do it
but you know actually slaps orange jelly
have you ever had orange jelly yes oh my
god that's like one of the most
refreshing desserts oh that is like
double nightmare for conor he doesn't
like jelly or oranges